here with reaction foxnews national
security strategist former deputy
assistant to the president
sebastian Gorka and foxnews contributor
herman cain sebastian we start with you
tonight these if these text messages
don't put it over the top for those that
have been trying to to cling like a
lifeline to this phony Russia you know
Trump narrative collusion narrative I
don't know what will
you're nothing nothing Shawn so let's
just put this into perspective very
simply put one of the most senior agents
at the FBI
responsible for the Hillary surrogate
investigation decided and put its in it
put it in a text message to his lover
I'm going to give Hillary special
treatment because hey she might be the
next president that is the definition of
the perversion of Justice that is the
definition of corruption and not
surprisingly The Daily Beast is already
behind the curve we know we know about
Comey we know about struck we know about
Rosenstein talking to my sources there
are 12 people 12 people in this
conspiracy at the highest level these
people mentioned in the memo
do you have this is this is not in the
memo this is phase two remember the memo
is the tip of the iceberg and Shawn I'm
worried because the GOP doesn't
understand strategic communications if
they don't release this memo now they
will lose the war in this communications
battlefield because they're being
diligent they're being very cautious but
the fact is you see ship out there
already spinning the Republicans are
taking weeks and months to get
everything double-checked who they will
lose the communications war and the
conspiracy will continue because these
people Shawn they're still at the FBI
they're still at the DOJ they should
have been stripped of their badge
stripped of their gun and perp walked
out of the Hoover Building months ago
how is it possible herman cain i think i
think dr. korkor raises a good point
that lisa struts to lose a job and elisa
page and peter struck how do they still
have jobs how does Andrew McCabe still
have a job how is it that James
homie is not under an investigation at
this point and all the others involved
in this how is that possible
it is possible because of the methods
that they know that they can use to
create barriers number one somebody
should go to jail and I agree with dr.
Gorka yes the Republicans need to insist
so all your viewers you should insist to
your representative and your Senators
release the memo the reason that most of
the Democrats on the intelligence
Oversight Committee didn't want to read
it is because they know it had damaging
information somebody should go to jail
and until they release that memo we
won't be able to get to the bottom of
this and let's face it the American
people are paying for this we deserve
transparency and the tea in transit
50,000 tattoos let's release all of them
yes now at least them all
release them why why don't they want to
release them it's very simple they have
something to hide from the American
people and from the public and they need
to release the memos and release the
memo that's pure and simple released a
memo and release the text dr. korkor yes
what we are learning tonight I know it
gets confusing I can put them back on
the side of the screen as you're
speaking here but did you look at what
struck and pager saying to each other it
is unbelievable to me that all of this
happened they still have a job now they
wanted to protect Hillary Clinton unless
she became president they had an
insurance policy now we know that Comey
mccabe struck page and Loretta Lynch all
knew she was never going to be indicted
that's not an investigation that's
called obstruction of justice especially
in light of what we know mishandling
classified information
felony destroying classified information
felony she did all of that and even
Comey said it and it gets worse then
destroying 33,000
females and then it gets worse then acid
washing and bleach pitting the hydro
hard drive so you never find them again
and who takes a hammer to bust up their
old Blackberry unless you're trying to
hide something and obstruct justice Shan
you you've outlined what Hillary did and
these are all felonies the private
server the destruction of evidence these
are all felonious activities we know
she's a criminal we know she had
accomplices but what's even worse is
that under the Obama administration
the FBI's management aided and abetted
her she wasn't sworn under oath her
evidence the laptops that they took from
her were destroyed not by Hillary they
were destroyed by the FBI they allowed
her best friend who was also a suspect
to act as her counsel in that interview
how did that happen that happened
because the Obama administration allowed
it to happen and the right name for all
of this Shan is Obama gait because if he
doesn't allow this to happen it doesn't
happen well I will tell you I never
thought Herman Cain in my lifetime that
we would see people at this level of
power literally thinking that they can
use a bought and paid for bony dossier
of Hillary Clinton to get a FISA warrant
first to lie to the American people and
propaganda is the American people with
Russian lies and then to use that very
dossier to get a FISA warrant to spy on
an opposition candidate in a
presidential election year and then use
it to undermine a president-elect this
is not a banana republic Herman Cain but
this is no stuff of a banana republic
Sean my last word is simply this
somebody is going to go to jail the only
question is who and when and I want to
remind people due process takes time but
somebody is going to jail just based
upon the information that we already
have and that we get the other
information from the memo and the
missing emails somebody is going to jail
and they should I have no doubt if we
have equal justice a little law and we
follow you and we believe in our
Constitution all of what you said should
come true
thank you both Herman Cain Sebastian